oh
you know i can't there's some of these
examples
that you give of
who this enemy was i just i just have to
read them
every day for three months they tortured
me azir recalled
from where he sat stranded on the
assyrian side
of the shuttered turkish border but
after a while
the torture just became routine he was
one of the thousands of prisoners
arrested by isis for so-called crimes
like wearing western jeans or smoking a
cigarette
but he was also one of a select few who
had managed to claw their way out of the
terrorist group's dungeons
with all his limbs intact
short of jail liberated by opposing
forces such escapes were considered rare
just
another another one nasra another former
captive
isis told us we will give you safety if
you give up your weapons
but they lied to us they took our
weapons and they arrested us
many of nasra's fellow soldiers had had
since been executed
but many remained incarcerated there was
no rights or to attorneys due process
trials or even a phone call he estimated
that as many as 2 000 iraqi armor
soldiers had been slain
since succumbing to isis over the past
two years he also estimated that 5
000 at that time remained in prison
bowels across the country
the cages were so small nazra said that
their torsos were marked by the folds of
skin
and their limbs tinged blue from the
hours of crouching
curled like a fetus in the womb
women arrested by isis typically
disappeared behind the prison's exterior
held
separately from the men and were often
never seen again
children are not exempt from the torment
either a large number of children have
been arrested by isis
my friend hassam a member of the syrian
activist group
raqqa is being slaughtered silently he
explained
the most common charges are insulting
allah and cooperating with apostates
they are being tortured just like men
and some of them have died under torture
they torture children too mostly
flogging beating on the hands and feet
and psychological torture i was
administered with electric shocks my
bones were broken
i was hung by my feet from the ceiling
and beaten with my hands tied behind my
back said ali
a professional in his mid-40s who had
been arrested in the early days of the
terrorist onslaught
on suspicion of being an atheist
they swore on a quran that i would be
cut to pieces
you make a note here you can take a life
without killing
that's what torture does
between the summers of 2015 and 2016
isis had been on an especially vicious
rampage to compensate for the loss of
seasoned soldiers
and to take into drugging those it
radicalized or first
forced into its lair isis is using
special tablets
the fighters take drugs and they don't
know where they are or what they are
doing
they are just shooting and fighting one
kurdish intelligence official explained
they lose their minds some can be shot
20 times before they go down
that ominous drug was known as captagon
is that right a methamphetamine-like
variant of the
banned pharmaceutical fentany
fentanypholine
it was manufactured in copious
quantities primarily in lebanon and
neighboring syria
where it was sold to isis through
middlemen
it removes any barriers you would have
the fighting
there is no second guessing they just go
out and kill
it's still a very common battlefield
drug often comes from lebanon or syria
um and yeah it's unfortunately it's
it goes just beyond isis but it's a very
common it's becoming a very common drug
that a lot of militias and even
government soldiers are sort of being
given to
to give them that sense of invincibility
to
have them go out there and and you know
do whatever they're told and
and i think yeah really it really gained
prominence under isis
um with little kids
yeah yep struggling them out
among the ranks of captured brainwashed
and drugs
drugged were scores of yazidi boys whose
minds had been twisted to turn against
their own people
they had been propelled into training
regimes that included islamist
indoctrination and weapons instruction
they had been forced into learning the
finer points of beheading
forced into becoming suicide bombers and
into serving
as human shields
so
did your perception
of evil
change while you were there
i think in the beginning
i perhaps had a little bit more of a
black and white um
perspective on it which i think you know
especially in the us
we tend to sort of think
which i think is completely wrong but we
tend to always it always comes down to a
religion thing
and and that always always is often
painted as the motivating factor
and i think what i really learned
from people that were joining isis it
was really one of
five things or one of you know ten
things that was motivating them to join
and so i think the complexities for me
really grew in that
because i suddenly started to see you
know and isis is absolutely evil and
that that hasn't changed for me
but what i started to see was the
complexities of
how they got to that point and why they
joined and it wasn't so black and white
really
and that majority of them
really were joining more out of a
necessity for survival than it
necessarily was
um some kind of you know
religious extremist religious extremism
however there is a difference between
the ones that were coming foreigners
were coming
and they were often a lot more extreme
in that respect
what i found for the iraqis in
particular that were joining
um was that a lot of them it was you
know isis had come in and taken over
their
town or their village and you know they
still needed to feed their family
um so you know those kind of
complexities grew
for me in it was a lot harder to look at
things in
in such sort of black and white terms
yeah i think you're right that america
definitely misses the point on that a
lot
um it was always i still i still have
conversations with people
that will talk to me about
or they'll come at me about you know we
had no reason to be fighting the iraqis
and i was like
hey we were fighting alongside the
iraqis
they were literally going into the same
buildings with us that's what they were
doing that
we were we weren't fighting against the
iraqis we were fighting against the
insurgents that were there
same thing with the um what you
mentioned about
you know how are we gonna how am i gonna
feed my family there's
plenty of 14
17 19 22 year old young male
iraqis that wanted money and how are
they going to get money well there's
someone over here that's going to pay
them 50
to go shoot an rpg at the coalition
forces and that's what they're going to
do
and they weren't jihadists they were
little hoodlums
just like a little hoodlum in america
that's how are you going to make them a
living in america
in in some crappy
city where you don't have any
opportunities oh i'm going to be a drug
dealer or i'm going to be a gang banger
because somebody's going to pay me
you know to go and carry this from here
to there it's it's an
economic decision more than anything
else and and you know even when they're
talking about
you know if it's a religious thing well
it can't be a religious thing
because we've got it's the actual
muslims fighting against the muslims
it's not like there's there's
it's not about that and what the other
crazy thing is you know when you when
you
talk to people and you know i would
explain well you know we were working
with
oftentimes a majority shia army
and it would be hard for them to
interact with the sunnis and people have
no
they don't understand what you're
talking about and that was a big
you know with isis is you know you
disbanded
an entire you know the sunnis were very
disbanded after saddam and yet they
still had their weapons and they're out
on the street and feeling
you know persecuted by by the government
and
so what are they going to do they're
going to band together it was the same
people it wasn't
it wasn't anything new i think isis was
sort of looked at as this
group that came out of nowhere and
dropped from the sky well no they
they were always there um they just kind
of
came together at some point when you
mentioned
baghdadi um abu bakr baghdadi
al-baghdadi
um we my task unit
in ramadi in 2006 went to go and
capture or kill him he had a mission to
go capture kill him
and didn't get him it's actually the
it's actually the opening story
leif leif babin was the ground force
commander on that operation
they got into a big gunfight because
there was security there which means he
was probably in that vicinity
but you're right well it's not these
aren't they didn't drop from the sky
this was a guy that had been there and
fought as an insurgent
and was on the run and constantly trying
to maneuver
and so yeah these people didn't drop
from the sky
and you know the other crazy thing that
you can compare to
a lot of bad situations in the world
where
what they want is there to be problems
what the what the insurgents want is to
create
division right division and they would
go and bomb
shia mosques just to get the shias to
lash out at the sunnis and then the
sunnis
they were trying to create a civil war
and it was
very very hard to walk that line and
make sure that you're
doing this in a proper way and even when
we in ramadi
when we got there in 2006 i thought we
were just gonna do a big sweep through
like we did
like like the marines did in fallujah
just go and rubble every building
and just run through it
and maliki the prime minister who was a
shia
knew that if he did that it would be bad
it would be bad and so he said no we're
not going to do that we're going to do
it in a more
sparing way as with minimal force
required and that's what we did there
was still force required but it was a
lot less
kinetic than fallujah was
so yeah i'll tell you
but um all that being said i i
the the the evil that's perpetrated is
just absolutely horrific and you capture
it in this book and
what scares me the most about it
is how easily people are swayed towards
it doesn't take much to push somebody
over the line from being a normal person
to beheading children
which is which is horrific
and you know i i i did one podcast on
the on the milai massacre
and there was roughly 500 old men
women and children no military age males
there at all
500 murdered raped mutilated
and the reading the interviews with the
guys that perpetrated this
and you read their backgrounds and you
read where they came from and you read
what they did
you can't it's we have to be on the
lookout for this kind of stuff
because these guys committed heinous
atrocities
equivalent of isis atrocities and they
were
americans that had crossed over the line
absolutely and i really think you know
and this is something i found in
afghanistan in
in syria and iraq and a lot of other
places that
we when i say we we just don't give
enough attention to and that is
government corruption and how much of
these things are a symptom
of that you know if you have to pay
someone every time you're going to go
through a checkpoint
you know so that some policeman can line
his pocket if you have to
if you see your leaders rolling around
with you know the in these fancy cars
and big houses and rolexes and and
and you're not you know you can't get by
you're sweeping in the street and still
not getting
any services then at some point it's
going to make you angry and when you're
angry
enough i also think it's a big factor
for
for joining a lot of these groups to
sort of rise up against their own
governments
and i think it's something that
when i talk to officials about it
they're often so quick to throw up their
hands
we can't do anything about that that's
just a systemic problem
okay but you're always going to be
dealing with terrorism as a
systemic problem from that problem
because
corruption is just such a huge driver of
it in
every way shape or form and i just think
it's something that gets barely any
attention
when it's such a a big reason
why these groups exist and continue to
exist and will continue to exist
yeah you have that um you have that
little bit of anger in the back your
mind that you're being oppressed
and then someone comes along and says
hey you can fight that oppression with
us
and i'm in let's do this yeah